abandoned Swades of the population is
what we were told by some of your
friends former friends today they
followed your lead on things like Europe
and immigration and you've abandoned
them how do you see it I've been rigidly
consistent I've said throughout my time
standing in democratic politics that my
priority is to get us out of the
European Union I've been tediously and
boringly rigidly consistent and you know
I think anyone in any doubt as to what I
wanted to achieve in politics is a no
doubt getting us out of the European
Union and we're beginning to see that
process delivered today you know I of
course I'll be one or two people in my
former party who will who will feel
aggrieved but this has always been about
more than just party politics it's been
about getting our country out of the
European Union and I'm pleased that that
process begins today so you Kip is dumb
now it's a busted flush we don't need
the party anymore I I want to talk
respectfully about some of the four
million people who voted you keep at the
last election but I'm making the journey
away from them because I feel job done I
feel today is a day when all you caters
and supporters and members can take real
satisfaction we should give ourselves a
medal or a knighthood know what no one
else is going to and we should take
quiet satisfaction that we made this
happen but you know i'm personally
making the journey away from you Kip if
others want to remain with the party I
wish them luck but I suspect that most
people who voted you Kip will recognize
job done and you know our 23 success
story as a party is tremendous but I I
don't really think that a party that's
principally about getting us out of the
EU can really complain given what the
government has now done so the party
should now be dissolved the work is done
I don't want to undermine good people if
they want to carry on as as you keep
members and campaigners but
fundamentally job job done we won for
goodness sake today marks the point when
the governing the government of the
United Kingdom realigned its priorities
after a 44-year error with the
priorities of folk in places like
clacton it's a wonderful day we've won
job done
why won't you say why are you backing
away from saying that it's all over for
the party then if the job is done for
you Kip and you no longer want to
represent you keep the only person to
represent you Kip within the House of
Commons why won't you say to people like
Aaron banks who finances UKF and Nigel
Farage who is less than complimentary
about you in fact our bank say that
you're borderline autistic and you have
a mental illness that's not very polite
is it why are you continuing to be
polite about the party I'm familiar with
the unkind comments that one or two
people in the upper echelons of my
former party if sometimes made about me
but I think it's really important in
politics to allow people to be
characterized by what they say I'm not
going to respond by saying unkind things
I hope people will judge me on what I
say I will never say unkind things about
any of the 17 and a half million people
who voted to leave the European Union
they're all good people as indeed and
many remain errs um you know if people
want to trade insults you know that
there are other other you know they
should stay on Twitter okay well let's
take you to where you stand now you're
an independent have it speaking to some
local you Kip supporters here and
councillors earlier on today just have a
quick listen this is what they had to
say standard that is not a violation
he's left the party it's no longer than
you keeping
type them voting from you keep NP he has
enough integrity to know that he should
be pulling the vile axis so I'm probably
be asking him why not I think he's got
any right just there's an MP in my
opinion and I think there should be a by
the two magazine doubt they're there I
just don't get it to those in other
words coming from that that he can
suspend
mr. Carswell there should be a
by-election is what your local
constituents think are you going to give
them one I'm familiar with the arguments
of some of those you could councillors
that you interviewed a couple of the
roach in the local Gazette a couple of
weeks ago saying that I should leave the
party I've now done what they demanded
in that letter I don't know why they're
not happy but fundamentally I'm not
changing party today in the House of
Commons i sat on the opposition benches
I would resign and trigger a by-election
if I was changing party as I did
previously I was the only member of the
House of Commons have done sewing I
think 45 years but I'm not ultimately
accepting the authority of another party
think about it if every time an MP lost
or resigned the whip they triggered a
by-election that would actually empower
the party bosses it may sound like a a
semantic difference but rather like a
decimal point it has major consequences
did you say that if twenty percent of
your constituents wanted a by-election
then you would trigger 1 i'm in favor of
the right of recall and I've advocated
the right of recall but expecting me to
trigger a by-election when I resign the
whip is is the precise opposite of what
a recall should do a recall should
strengthen the voters against the party
bosses if every time someone lost or
resigned the whip that force them to
have a by-election that would be the
antithesis of recoil it would strengthen
the party bosses look I'm hyper
accountable to voters and I'm incredibly
grateful for you for explaining what
voters in my constituency think since i
left my house at seven thirty this
morning I can't imagine their attitudes
have changed a great deal I know a great
deal about what my constituents thing I
wrote over 20,000 of them on this very
subject I have had literally thousands
of responses and they're overwhelmingly
positive my question remains I'll pose
it to you again twenty percent if they
said that they wanted a by-election
would you give them one yeah I'm not
triggering a by-election and you know
several days on from my decision to
resign the width there will be no
by-election in clacton and you know I
I'm absolutely watertight on this issue
and I think the overwhelming majority of
my constituents are on my side on this
you may have found some you kick ass you
feel a bit huffy but you know frankly
that tells you more about party politics
than my constituents okay so Nigel
Farage says he's going to write to every
single constituents and say you know
what you should push this man for a
by-election because he's no longer
representing you as he said that he
would how do you feel about him doing
that it's wonderful Nigel giving advice
on how to engage with constituents and
engage with constituency opinion he's
got quite a lot of form on this but with
respect I I think him that 20,000 plus
that i wrote to have responded in a way
that's overwhelmingly positive yet
Nigel's got some great thoughts on how
to engage with opinion in a
parliamentary constituency it's not
always worked out well for him you've
never been a comfortable kippur though
have you the Tories would be delighted
to have you back is it crossed your mind
I'm again trying to explain that it is
possible I've been consistent in wanting
to get out of the European Union I've
gone into politics saying that that's
what I want to achieve and and and yet
you somehow cast aspersions on all my
motives for being consistent why not ask
a minister who perhaps got selected as a
Tory MP by sounding Euroskeptic then
campaign for remain and now wants to
vote leave when I asked them about
consistency I've been tediously
consistent on this issue I'm a little
surprised that you're casting aspersions
on my motives i i i want what i say i
want which is to get us out of the
european union today we're achieving
that I don't understand why my former
party can't be happy I'm asking you
these questions because I'm in your
constituency and your constituents are
posing these questions as we were
speaking to them today the party that
you previously represented are also
asking why on earth if you no longer
represent that party you won't have a
by-election I'm also putting it to you
that the conservatives would be
delighted to have you back as one of
their own and lots of conservatives also
supported at leaving the European Union
so that would seem potentially quite a
good fit why I I wish this government
well and I will be supporting the
government on some key issue
is to make sure that they deliver on
their brexit mandate but I don't really
feel under any inclination to rejoin the
concern apart from anything if i was to
rejoin the consolers consistent with
what I've just told you I'd need to
trigger a by-election and I'm not about
to do that but look it's perfectly
possible surely in this day and age to
be in favor of what a prime minister is
doing and supportive of their policy but
also to hold them to account for when
they get things wrong and perhaps you
know you can expect me in the tradition
of a national liberal or a liberal
unionist and so Julian ridgedale who
represented michael acton constituency
for nearly 50 years was a liberal
unionist and III think he would have
understood exactly what I meant when I
said I'll support the government where
they need supporting and opposed them
when it's right to oppose them final
sort you're running scared really they
want you you think that you might not
win a by-election which is why you
weren't calm because if you were cast
iron you would call do I strike you as
someone who's a particularly scared of
by-elections I've triggered a by
actually do X I want it yes I'm not even
triggered I sink into my election but I
triggered and one of my election and
enjoy the largest swing to any party in
any election in British history I i love
referendums I love by-election so I love
general elections